-My first guests tonight are
co-hosts of "Morning Joe,"
which airs weekday mornings
at 6:00 a.m. on MSNBC.
Here are Joe Scarborough
and Mika Brzezinski!
-Hey, how you doing?
-Nice to see you.
There's a lot I want to
talk to you both about.
First of all, thank you for just
surviving this election cycle.
This has been pretty crazy.
-Or a presidency.
-Yeah, no, it's been
a crazy four or five years,
so I think all of us
are exhausted.
We actually thought
before 2016 --
we told our boss,
Phil Griffin, at MSNBC.
I said, "Listen, after Hillary
wins, this is exhausting."
-Take a break.
-"We're going to take --
we're going to take
about a two-month break."
-[ Laughs ]
-And that never happened.
-Never.
-No.
And I also want to mention,
congrats on your anniversary.
Is it two years married
for you guys?
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, you know,
it's very interesting, Jimmy,
you say that.
Actually, I know that.
-Thank you!
I know that too.
-And you know that.
-I know that.
-Uh-oh.
-But right before
we came on the show,
I turned to Mika...
-No, I know that.
-...and I said, "Hey, do you
know what today is, honey?"
And she said, "Uh, no, why?"
-No, come on.
-Oh, my goodness.
-It's our two-year anniversary.
She still doesn't know
what month I was born in.
So that's my birthday.
-Listen.
-So it doesn't matter.
-When we did the show
this morning and I said
what the date was to everybody,
something hit me
that it was a special day.
-You knew it was special.
-No.
-Yeah.
-It was something about it.
-Something.
-Some of us -- Some of us knew
it was special,
and it really is now.
Now it's doubly special.
Congrats on that, guys.
I love seeing you guys together.
I love seeing you
separately as well.
But together, it's unbelievable.
It's magic.
You guys were hosting
a special Saturday edition.
They kept adding these special
editions of your show,
of "Morning Joe."
-Yeah, it just kept going.
-And, man, I honestly --
I applaud you.
Thank you so much.
The American people thank you
for just being on the air.
But you -- MSNBC made the call
that Joe Biden
had become President-elect.
Joe, what was it like for you
to make that announcement?
-Well, you know,
something happened to me
that's never happened before
in like -- what? --
17 years in television.
I had somebody say into my ear
that Joe Biden is going...
-Alex.
-...to be the 46th President
of the United States.
Our EP Alex said that.
And I was supposed to, you know,
do the Brian Williams --
"We have just received..."
-He's good at it.
-"...word that Joe Biden
will be the next President
of the United States."
I got, "Joe Biden is,"
and then I had to stop.
-And I got worried.
-The last thing I wanted to do
was have anybody hear
any emotion in my voice.
We were, especially since
it was election coverage,
I wanted to play it
straight down the middle.
Everybody knew
that we were supporting
Joe Biden over President Trump.
But at the same time,
the last thing I wanted to do
was get emotional.
-Start crying.
-With a Cronkite moment,
taking off my glasses.
So I said, "Mika."
-Yeah.
-And she said --
then she did the whole thing.
-Well, your work has paid off.
MSNBC and your show
in particular
have been fantastic
in the ratings.
So congrats on that if that
makes you feel any better.
But I don't even know
if you care.
At this point,
you're like, "Let's just --"
-Nope.
-"We just want a weekend off."
-Yes.
-Yeah, exactly.
-It feels like there's
never been a slow news day
during Trump's presidency.
-There hasn't been.
In fact, since the campaign,
and as Joe said, we wanted --
every time you would
want to take a break,
every time you go take a break,
it follows you.
And now, literally,
in this pandemic,
you cannot leave your job.
It is there with you 24/7.
And with this president,
it has been one you-know-what
after another.
-Yeah, is this going to
change the pace
of all news shows in general?
-I hope. I mean, don't you hope?
-Yeah.
-I'd take boring.
We can't wait to be boring.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-Yeah, I mean, I do think,
though, actually one
of the problems
over the past four years --
actually probably over
the past couple of decades --
is that politics
has become a blood sport.
People turn to their channel.
-You call it a shock opera.
-Yeah, it is a shock opera,
and people root for their team,
root for their side.
-I think we've been
desensitized as well
to shocking news
from the presidency.
And it's going to take
a long time to unwind this,
no matter what side
of this you're on.
-Yeah, and both sides
watch your show.
I will say that, too.
I mean, it's good to have
the conversation with them.
-Absolutely.
-Yeah, it is.
And I think, you know, we used
to go and give an awful lot
of speeches to civic groups,
and we just stopped doing it
over the past several years
in colleges because things
became so intense.
It used to be
that Mika would get up
and she would take
the more liberal view.
I'd take
the more conservative view.
-We switched all around.
-We had this really
fun back-and-forth.
And let's just say the fun
has gone away a little bit
in the past couple years when it
comes to talking about politics.
Let's hope we can get back to a
place where we can talk civilly
about it again
and at least be operating
from the same set of facts.
-[ Chuckles ] Well, Jimmy,
when the show started --
So, I was sort of
the straight man.
And then I saw myself
on "Saturday Night Live"
and realized what's happened
over the past four years
is we've switched roles.
-Yeah.
-And I've become the crazy one.
-You know, the funny thing is
everybody called us --
-He's driven me crazy!
-Not me -- Donald Trump.
-Do you think that
he is going to concede?
No, he's not going
to concede, right, Mika?
-Nope.
-No.
-We have a bet on this.
That's all I'm going to say,
and I'm going to win.
And it's a lot because I bet --
when I bet,
I bet for a lot of money.
-Yeah.
Joe, why do you think that it's
taking so long for Republicans
to acknowledge Biden's win?
-Yeah, I wish I knew.
You know, I was --
These people were my colleagues.
I served with them...
-Your friends.
-...when I was young.
When I was 30,
I got elected to Congress
and I served with
a lot of these people
for eight years in Congress.
Seven, eight years in Congress.
And I've known them for
almost a quarter of a century,
and I just don't recognize
some of them.
I mean, these are people
that we worked together.
We fought the good fight
together.
We were used to -- you know,
there were a lot of times
when many of us were trying to
run Newt Gingrich out of town
and sort of leading a coup
against his speakership.
And we were doing it
because we didn't feel like
he was following his word,
that he was keeping his word.
And to see a lot of these people
just sort of blindly follow
Donald Trump over the past
four years and say nothing
when President Trump actually
was talking the last two weeks
of the campaign about
throwing Joe Biden in jail,
having his attorney general
throw Joe Biden in jail.
That's something
that happens in Russia.
It's bizarre,
and I just kept waiting for
my friends to speak up,
and they just didn't do it.
-You never got,
like, a little wink,
like a little Jack Nicholson,
like "Cuckoo's Nest" like --
-Yeah.
-Nothing.
-Yeah, they all do.
No, they will all give you
the little wink off camera.
And they go, "Yeah, we know
he's crazy. Yeah, yeah.
But that really does
none of us any good.
People needed to start
saying it on camera,
and for whatever reason,
they just couldn't bring
themselves to do it.
-There's more I want to
talk to you guys about.
Can you stick around
for a couple more minutes?
-Would love to.
-Absolutely.